we've got some breaking news from New
York for you video shows an apparent
bomb explodes in just west of Times
Square that is causing chaos for the
city's commuters a man is in custody
after a device went off in a passenger
walkway underneath the Port Authority
Bus Terminal that is the city's main bus
station
fire officials say four people were hurt
including the suspect DeMarco Morgan is
at the scene DeMarco good morning good
morning to you that explosion happened
just before eight o'clock this morning
and as a result there is massive police
force here in midtown Manhattan you can
see here behind me one of the avenues is
completely blocked off making this a
large crime scene in this area this is
what we're hearing right now
aside from New York City's Police
Commissioner calling this a terrorist
incident a source tells CBS News
it happened in a pedestrian tunnel a law
enforcement source says the man is from
Bangladesh and was apparently carrying a
5-inch pipe bomb he was apparently
carrying it when it exploded in his
stomach area he was taken to a hospital
but its injuries are not believed to be
life-threatening police say he is in
custody and the federal law enforcement
official says the device malfunctioned
and may not have fully detonated New
York Governor Andrew Cuomo described the
device there was an explosion
the police commissioner will go over the
details it was a minor it was an
effectively low-tech device there were
several injuries we hope minor this
happened in the middle of the morning
rush hour just before 8 o'clock this
morning the Port Authority Bus Terminal
is America's biggest and busiest bus
station about two hundred thousand
commuters use it just about every
weekday so you can only imagine what
people were thinking when that explosion
happened at the time that this possible
pipe bomb exploded here we are still
learning more about this information
actually our Governor Cuomo police are
still here on the scene addressing
reporters we'll continue to update you
as soon as we learn much more on this
breaking and developing story for now
with some things back to you